>> Kat: A LEGEND IN THE NATIONAL
BASKETBALL ASSOCIATION WANTS TO
TRY HOSTAGE NEGOTIATION.
WILL DENNIS RODMAN PUT ON
EYELINER TO GO AND SAVE BRITTNEY
GRINER?
THAT'S A GOOD ONE.
NBA HALL OF FAMER DENNIS RODMAN
SAYS HE'S HEADED TO RUSSIA TO
HELP GET BRITTNEY GRINER BACK.
YOU'LL RECALL GRINER, AN
AMERICAN WNBA PLAYER, IS
CURRENTLY BEING HELD THERE ON A
NINE-YEAR PRISON SENTENCE FOR
CANNABIS POSSESSION.
HOPEFULLY SHE CAN RETURN TO THE
U.S. WHERE THE ONLY PUNISHMENT
WOULD BE HAVING TO PLAY IN THE
WNBA.
ACCORDING TO RODMAN, HE'S
RECEIVED PERMISSION TO TRAVEL
OVERSEAS TO AID HER RETURN.
ALTHOUGH IT'S NOT CLEAR WHO IF
ANYONE AUTHORIZED RODMAN TO WORK
IN A DIPLOMATIC CAPACITY.
BACK IN 2017 DENNIS RODMAN
CLAIMS TO HAVE GOSH 88ED THE
RETURN OF AUTO WARMBIER WHO WAS
HELD CAP STAVE IN NORTH KOREA
AND HE FAMOUSLY HAS HAD A CHUMMY
RELATIONSHIP WITH NORTH KOREA'S
DICTATOR KIM JONG-UN.
NOW HE SAYS HE ALSO KNOWS
VLADIMIR PUTIN, TOO.
EVEN CALLING HIM COOL IN A 2014
INTERVIEW.
WHETHER OR NOT DENNIS ACTUALLY
TRAVELS TO RUSSIA IS LIKE A WNBA
GAME.
YOU DON'T KNOW IF ANYONE WILL
EVER SEE IT.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Kat: BUTs DISCLOSURE ANYONE,
I'M A LITTLE BIAS.
SO BEFORE WE GET INTO THE
DISCUSSION WE'VE GOT TO PLAY
THIS.
>> SO DENNIS RODMAN IS REALLY,
REALLY HOT AND ALWAYS HAS BEEN
SO PLEASE EXCUSE EVERYTHING
SHE'S ABOUT TO SAY.
IF YOU DISAGREE WITH IT IT'S NOT
HER FAULT HE'S SO HOT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Kat: EVERYONE'S LIKE IS SHE
JOKING?
I'M NOT JOKING.
DOUGLAS I'VE HAD A HUGE CRUSH ON
DENNIS RODMAN SINCE I WAS LIKE
FIVE YEARS OLD.
AM I GOING TO BE OKAY?
>> Douglas: YOU WANT HIM TO COME
AND SAVE YOU?
>> Kat: I FEEL LIKE I HAVE TO
PLAY HARDER TO GET THAN THAT
>> Douglas: YOU SHOULD TAKE
DRUGS TO RUSSIA.
>> Kat: I KNOW
>> Douglas: I KNEW IF GREG
WASN'T HERE WE WOULD HAVE TO DO
A CAT DRUGS JOKE.
IT'S VERY STRANGE I WAS IN NORTH
KOREA SOME YEARS AGO AND I
DISCOVERED PEOPLE THERE KNOW
ALMOST NOBODY FROM THE OUTSIDE
WORLD, ALMOST NOBODY.
THEY'VE HEARD OF CHAIR MAN MAU
AND THEY'VE HEARD OF DENNIS
RODMAN.
CAN YOU IMAGINE WHAT A STRANGE
WORLD THAT IS?
THEY THINK HE'S LIKE SOME
MAGICAL.
>> Kat: HOT GUY
>> Douglas: I WAS GOING TO SAY
LIKE SOME INTERNATIONAL DIPLOMAT
AND THEY DON'T SEEM TO REALIZE
THAT HERE HE'S JUST DENNIS
RODMAN AND ONLY YOU HAVE THIS
GREAT LOVE OF HIM.
AND, YEAH, ANYHOW, YOU'D LOVE
NORTH KOREA.
THEY HOLD HIM IN THE SAME ESTEEM
AS YOU DO.
>> Kat: IF YOU CAN CONTROL WHO
YOU DO AND DO NOT THINK IS HOT,
THAT WOULD BE BETTER.
OKAY, BUT IT'S LIKE, DAGEN, WHO
WOULD BE A BETTER NEGOTIATOR DO
YOU THINK, JOE BIDEN OR DENNIS
RODMAN?
I DENNIS RODMAN IS ALWAYS GREAT
PUT ON DISPLAY BECAUSE IT
REMINDS ALL YOUNG PEOPLE THAT
FACIAL PIERCINGS DON'T AGE VERY
WELL.
[LAUGHTER].
>> Dagen: BUT I DID START
THINKING IF I GOT STUCK OVERSEAS
BECAUSE I HAD LIKE WEED JUICE IN
MY SUITCASE, WHO DO I WANT TO
COME RESCUE ME?
AND I FIGURED ROUGHLY CROW, HE'S
A AUSTRALIAN HE DOESN'T NEED TO
GET PERMISSION FROM THE
GOVERNMENT AND EVEN THOUGH HE'S
PRETTY PUFFY NOW, I'M STILL DOWN
TO MEET HIM.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Kat: WHY ARE YOU LOOKING AT
ME LIKE THAT?
>> Tyrus: I'VE GOTTEN USED TO IT
OVER SEVEN YEARS.
I'M JUST SO HAPPY RODMAN HAS A
JOB.
THAT'S COOL.
I'M SURE YOUR HUSBAND WAS
STOKED.
>> Kat: OH, HE ALREADY KNOWS.
YEAH.
HE ALREADY KNOWS.
>> Tyrus: YOU KNOW, DENNIS
RODMAN BUILT A REPUTATION AS ONE
OF THE MOST FEROCIOUS ATHLETES
ON THE PLANET, DROVE GUYS CRAZY
ON THE COURT AND HAD THIS
CONSULT FOLLOWINGS OVERSEAS
BECAUSE HE DID THINGS NO ONE
ELSE COULD DO, HE DEFENDED
PEOPLE.
HE WAS ANNOYING EVERYONE WANTED
TO PUNCH HIM AND BEAT HIM UP BUT
HE WAS INSANELY TOUGH.
SO THESE DICTATORS WERE KIND OF
DRAWN TO HIM BECAUSE HE'S LIKE
IF THEY PLAY BASKETBALL, BECAUSE
THEY COULDN'T SHOOT TO SAVE
THEIR LIVELIES.
BASKETBALL.
PEOPLE THEY'RE GOOD AT.
I SHOULD SEE THEIR STATS, IT'S
PHENOMENAL.
I HAVE TO BE CAREFUL.
BUT HE HAD THAT REPUTATION WHERE
MICHAEL JORDAN WE ALWAYS LOVED
HIM HERE WITH HIS SHOES, BUT
DENNIS RODMAN HAD SOMETHING
SPECIAL, I THINK DEEP DOWN YOUNG
AND PUTIN WANTED TO DO THE HAIR.
THEY WERE LIKE THIS IS HOW I
WANT TO BE, TOUGH AND PRETTY.
SO HE'S PROBABLY THE BEST CHOICE
TO GO OVER.
BECAUSE THEY LET HIM OVER.
WE'RE SAYING WE DON'T KNOW WHO
LET HIM OVER.
PUTIN LED HIM OVER WE JUST DON'T
WANT TO GET HIM MAD AT US, IF WE
HAVE MORE ISSUES, WE WON'T SEND
TRUMP, SEND DENNIS, HE'LL FIX IT
AND GET US BACKUP VOTES.
I DON'T CARE HOW HE SPRAINS IT
PAINTS IT, HE'LL GO OVER THERE
AND I BET HE BRINGS IT BACK.
BECAUSE HE'S DENNIS [BLEEP]
RODMAN
>> Kat: JIMMY DO YOU THINK HE
CAN DO IT?
>> Jimmy: WE'RE REALLY IN A
PICKLE HERE BETWEEN THE WHOLE
RODMAN BIDEN THING BECAUSE WHEN
YOU THINK ABOUT PAST PERFORMANCE
ON THE WORLD STAGE THOUGH, LIKE
ONE GUY ALWAYS FLIES TO OTHER
COUNTRIES AND SOUNDS LIKE HE'S
DONE DRUGS AND THE OTHER GUY'S
LIKE DENNIS RODMAN.
WE HAVE NOTHING TO LOSS TYRUS IS
RIGHT, AT LEAST BRITNEY REINER
WILL GET A CONTACT HIGH OFF OF
RODMAN WHICH IS GOOD.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT ELSE WE SHOULD
DO BECAUSE THERE'S BEEN NO
MOVEMENT ON THIS.
YOU FEEL LIKE UNDER PAST
DISCIPLINE STRAKESS WE WOULD BE
ON A VERY ASSERTIVE LEVEL OF
ENGAGEMENT BUT I STILL THINK
BIDEN THINGS WNBA THINKS THAT'S
A RADIO STATION IN DELAWARE SO
NOTHING'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
>> IT WAS LONNIE ANDERSON.
.
>> Kat: DENNIS I BELIEVE IN